welcome back to the show o'shea jackson
jr who uh last we checked was not
suspended from twitter no
right o'shea oh but i'm i'm trying rich
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations sir congratulations you
must be so
through the roof congrats yeah man
i i'm feeling good i got a little bit of
a toothache though because i've been
brushing my teeth with champagne for the
last three days
you know it's uh it's having some bad
after effects but i'm feeling pretty
good i'm feeling like uh
i'm feeling right you know i'm feeling
right okay so
we learned that vuvclico has no fluoride
in it so we figured that out
okay so we learned that um and then we
learned that uh
you you you you doused yourself before
you put the goggles on are you okay did
you get any in your eyes
with the making that video it burns it
burns aggressively
i uh you know they're they're it when
you're victorious though you feel no
pain
but it's it's definitely a stinging
sensation in the eyes
right but it's you know it's great it's
one of my favorite videos i've ever
posted online
so uh you've been adding a lot of people
in the media
o'shea you've been adding a lot of
people
what's up with that i just
let me tell you something about lakers
rich we are
by far the most annoying fan base that
you could ever find
and we're sensitive and we uh you know
i i promised laker fans that if we won
it all yes
then i would be the tax man and when you
have to pay the tax man
you have to bring the receipts and i'm
going to make sure
that everyone who chose that other team
the clippers
or you know heat and seven
or blazers and see any any of those i
want an apology
i just want an apology that's all we
want i just want to hear them tell me
they were wrong
and they're lucky that we're in a
pandemic or i would be
on their shows visibly full-on mori
povich style
like uh my man brian windhorst he told
me
that the clippers were better put
together team that the lakers would be a
work in progress
and the finals results showed that was a
lie i don't
have time for these shenanigans and i
want my apology and i will get them rich
so this is a media audit
is what you're saying this is an audit
o'shea
oh yeah i'm going wait as a matter of
fact is my man chris there
he is there yeah okay what's happening
man
what's up dude um so you remember
back when i was promoting godzilla king
the monsters and
i believe your quote was the delusional
laker fan
is the best laker fan and then you said
that the celtics
were four minutes away from the finals
do you remember that i do they were i
was at the game they were four minutes
from the finals that's correct
okay chris how many minutes from the
finals are they now
well let's see if we backlogged the six
games and then the seventh against
miami yeah i'm sorry man look man i just
remembered you the most
i get i get what you do rich i get you
know i can
you poke at me jamal murray blah blah
blah but you're a celtic chris
i know you were the first person i
thought of man i just want you to know
why look and look i i i appreciate you
admitting that laker fans are the most
annoying
and uh i think you're just proving my
point that like
you know delusional intense annoying
laker fan
is the best laker fan look it wouldn't
be a rivalry if the boston teams won all
the time so it's nice to have you guys
back man
i love the enthusiasm bro uh you know i
really wish
i really was hoping that lebron would
get his first title against the celtics
but
you know how disappointing they can be
so i i'm just glad that he got it done
the storybook ending for kobe was the
most
important thing to me i expressed that
to you guys so much
i wanted this so bad for kobe because it
just couldn't be
any other team for it to be the season
that we lost him
and and to end it this way it uh
it's not it's probably my second
favorite championship i've ever been
upon
all right i'll bite what's the first
oh for sure kobe beating boston what are
you talking about
last time during the finals and they
lost to the lakers
yeah that was my favorite time for sure
oh
baby wow so how many how many are you
thinking now all right because as you
know greed is good
greed is good one of the best lines in
movie history the greed for the lack of
a better phrase is good and sports is
all about being greedy how many do you
think you're getting how many do you
think this is the beginning of
let's be honest go forward um for sure
i know i know personally yes uh
i want i want two more at least out of
bronze
you know i i know that uh it's the 17th
year
i know that the lakers usually when you
win the championship rich i've
you know the lakers have won a lot of
these when you win the championship oh
boy
a lot of the free agents out there on
the market they kind of add to your team
so i'm expecting this lakers team to be
even better
well they they got it they've got to be
from clutch sports though o'shea it
can't be just from anybody right
listen rich paul will get it done i
no no he's not the general manager no no
no it's it's polinka who's the general
manager
okay oh oh listen once once we get
rich paul to sign him the clutch rob you
know once you get to live rob palinka
will throw that thing
in it's a really good deal that we got
going but i want two more
two more i feel like okay i'll build the
statue myself rich
like if if i get two more plus it'll put
braun
uh at wait if i get two more yeah he'll
put him at six
and um you know then he he wants to be
he wants that goat he wants that goat
without
you know without any questioning and of
course like i'm a laker so i'm expecting
superstars to come here and join and uh
yeah life is good right now
they told me that i wouldn't win it this
year and i'd have a better chance next
year
and so with me winning and having a
better chance next year i'm expecting
more parades
so do you get a ring you're going to get
a ring
obviously bro
i got to get a ring bro will you have
your own float in the parade
when we get back to parading that would
be great you should
oh oh listen don't don't hype me up guys
you already know where i'm gonna go with
this
and to everybody hold on one more thing
to everyone who has something to say
oh the lakers had to wait 10 years 10
years is so long
i'm sorry i'm not a phoenix son i'm
sorry i'm not a memphis grizzly
or a charlotte hornet or any of these
other teams
10 years is a lifetime for a laker
so get mad get glad get heavyweight
trash bags
i'm sorry you don't really sound sorry
i'll be honest with you i don't i don't
hear any
any sorry in that i think you're just
you're look you're
you're we're all just paying rent you
know it's interesting because we osha
jackson junior a few more minutes left
with uh with o'shea here on the rich
island show we we
we pulled a piece of video from a chat
that i had with kobe
in 2018 just after lebron got here
where i said to him you know what what
does lebron need to
do in order to achieve
you know your status here in los
angeles i'm paraphrasing the question
but that's basically the gist of it
and kobe's response was essentially in
the most
kind way possible to not stir anything
up oh you got this exchange here
just listen to this exchange this is
great what do you think
um he needs to accomplish here in order
to be
viewed in a similar vein
as say you as a laker kobe well i don't
know
the making the comparisons of him being
viewed in a similar vein is me i mean
that doesn't make
much sense right i mean i you know i
think the goal is always to win
championships no matter where you go
that's the goal and that's his goal
that's rob's goal that's magic's goal
that's genie's goal
rondo all the guys so he he needs to win
a championship here
you know how do people why do people
always say that they say okay well you
need to and then there's this this like
crowd of people that are like
well you don't need to win a champion
well you're asking me
you have to win championships this is
why we play this is why we're here is to
win championships
and you know he want to came here if he
he didn't expect to win championships
what'd you think of that that's just
dynamite all of it where he's just like
yeah i don't
i don't think it's fair comparison for
him to me here
and then he says when i say he doesn't
need to win he goes why do people say
that and then he basically says
it's not need it's expect i just loved
every aspect of that
i loved all of it just revisiting it it
was basically rick james on eddie
murphy's couch like
i loved all of it yeah but he's right
he's absolutely right
you know lebron's 10-year year like
20 years 20 years is not going to be
touched it's not going to be in the same
light as kobe what kobe did
for laker fans around the world and
especially in los angeles
is touch our spirit in a way that just
cannot
be duplicated and he he put a
a level of of of pride in
us in our everyday jobs no matter what
we do
we try to give that mamba mentality so
that that will never be tough but as far
as being a laker great it
is about winning championships i don't
care how
great wilt was if he didn't win a ring
here
he's not going to be hanging up there
with the rest of them and now lebron
has his ring uh i put them up there
if you give me two more you know we like
you're like
great they're like great um i'm very
appreciative of
all the fans that even still have
something to say about lebron james
they just don't know what's in front of
them and if you spend all your time
hating
you won't be able to be appreciated and
i'm so appreciative of
lebron his his mindset razon rondo
rajon rondo gave the celtics their 17th
and the lakers their 17th that's my
favorite part of the rivalry for sure
this whole team like it's it's something
that
that laker fans no matter how you feel
about kobe about braum
you better take the time and smell your
flowers and i'm gonna make sure
that the media gives our respect because
they get to hear me
until tip off of next season they're so
lucky rich they get to hear my voice for
so long
the media auditor the tax man o'shea
jackson jackson thanks for joining us
o'shea i always enjoy the chats congrats
of course man go lakers and clippers i
told you so
okay there you go leave me out of this
that's calling mike
o'shea jackson jr
that's great